sitzt in einem pfleger von berlin nach
köln jeher inlandsflüge ist es dein herz
stets in einem flieger von barcelona
nach köln plötzlich kommt eine durchsage
alles nur ein traum
mir kommt allerdings eine frage wie
schwer ist es ohne erfahrung ein
flugzeug zu machen what the [ __ ] sehr
guter anfang für dieses video
[Musik]
also ich bin naif attraktion im neuen
video nachrede ich zu schnell oder hört
ihr zu langsam zu ich habe in meinem
cannabis video das letzte woche kamen
gemerkt dass es sich vielleicht manchmal
lohnt leuten zuzuhören die plan haben
und nicht einfach irgendeine scheiße
drauf los zu laufen damit ich erstmal
gefühl fürs fliegen bekommen kann habe
ich einen kumpel angerufen der christen
krassen beruf hat er ist und was er
macht erzählt euch aber einfach mal
selbst samt flughafen und neben einer
menge flugzeugen also wirklich hier
besteht ja auch ein ganz besonderes
flugzeug das flugzeug in dem wir gleich
über könnten werde ich meine guckt euch
das einfach mal an dass sie haben vier
sitzplätze da drin ist es komplett
gestört und alte wird uns heute
hoffentlich sicher herum segeln für alle
flugbegeisterten unter euch hier einmal
ein paar kurze aufnahmen das wie malte
sagt vogel
[Musik]
auch die angelehnt wirklich niemand mehr
machen weiter
weiter hat das flugzeug dann extrem
sorgfältig geprüft alle wichtigen
stellen werden penibel kontrolliert und
anhand einer checkliste getestet und ich
mich versah saßen wir dann schon im
rollenden flugzeug richtung startbahn
und dann haben wir circa anderthalb
stunden flug von aachen über köln zurück
nach aachen genutzt wir sind wirklich
mitreden über die stadt in köln geflogen
wir haben kreise um den dom gedreht wir
haben ein logo coach am kölner flughafen
geflogen das bedeutet diesen sehr nah an
den boden geflogen und einfach mit
vollgas über die komplette landebahnen
heißt wir sind ziemlich steilen kurven
geflogen und hat uns einfach ein
bisschen gezeigt was das flugzeug so
kann bis unseren beiden mit fliegern
paul und l wann das dann ein bisschen zu
viel wurde
außerdem hat mir malte so die basics der
instrumente erklärt und es war ziemlich
den ganzen punkt verkehr mitzubekommen
und eigentlich war das gar nicht so
schwer zu verstehen um das ganze zu
perfektionieren dauert natürlich
ewigkeiten aber um grundverständnis
dafür zu bekommen hat was auf jeden fall
geholfen und natürlich hat uns unser
lieblings pilot wieder alle sicher auf
den boden gebracht hallo ich bin etwas
der zukunft wenn diese anwendung kommt
wisst ihr was zu tun ist halt einfach
meine fresse viel spaß weiter mit dem
video ist was zu tun ist traum alter die
vielen dank ich hoffe es war nicht alles
so schrecklich alter komplett gestört es
ist zu gestört aber die große frage ist
ob es mir möglich ist so ein ding zu
fliegen um zu lernen und genau das
problem wir jetzt aus also habe ich
innerhalb von einem tag im flugsimulator
in köln organisiert damit alles
möglichst realistisch ist habe ich mich
für den simulator einer airbus a320
entschieden was vermutlich am weitesten
verbreitete maschine für kurzstrecken
ist welchen ihr jedenfalls in eurem
leben nach mallorca berlin das lohner
london oder sonstwohin geflogen seit war
es vermutlich genau mit dieser maschine
nimm2 sehr unwahrscheinlichen aber doch
möglichen fall würde man die maschine
mit hilfe des autopiloten zusammen dafür
habe ich mit meinem instructor den
funkverkehr simuliert und er hat mir nur
durch beschreiben erklärt welche knöpfe
ich wie zu verstellen haben die genau
vor sie schauen sehen sie zwei kleine
monitore daneben ist eine 10er taste
rechts neben dem monitor in der mitte
des flugzeuges neuen konsole vor ihnen
obwohl keine zu einer passagiere in
gefahr sind obwohl nichts kaputt gehen
kann und obwohl der simulator keine
hydraulik hat die ihn bewegen lässt hat
es sich um fassbar realistisch angefühlt
und ich war extrem gestresst ich hatte
schwitzige hände ein schlechtes
kurzzeitgedächtnis und manchmal
verständnisschwierigkeiten nachdem wir
mehrere minuten geflogen sind habe ich
mich immer wohler gefühlt zwar immer
noch nicht in der lage dieses ding zu
wenden aber ein bisschen wohler
um euch die ganze prozedur vor der
landung zu ersparen habt ihr das ganze
hier als zeitraffer gesehen jetzt kommt
es aber zum entscheidenden teil kulturen
wird habe ich gehört
100 über entscheidung so ist die waren
vor ihnen gut wir fliegen lassen die
bahn ist vier kilometer lang
sagen sie mir wenn sie über der bahn
sind er wolle
[Musik]
jetzt einen schubhebel zurück auf null
na ja so ganz leicht anheben er hat nur
den flieger auf der bahn halten die
rechte hand ist noch aufschub
weiter zurückgehen da ist ein kleiner
knopf steht auf park über den hochheben
nach rechts drehen
jawohl
frauke
die oftmals lass mich raten
eine komplette
stop stop shop freunde ihr könnt jetzt
vielleicht denken dass das jetzt alles
war ich habe es zwar geschafft dieses
flugzeug mit allen hilfsmitteln zu
landen was passiert aber wenn ich darauf
keinen zugriff mehr haben genau das
wollte ich durch den weiteren versuch
heraus der instructor hat mir durch
ansagen dabei geholfen das flugzeug zu
starten
görlitz
wie ohren jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr
j
rage kommt auf den schwarzen brocken ist
der grüne kirchlich da dann allerdings
ein neuer kunde kamen der bedient werden
musste sah sich völlig allein ohne
jegliche hilfe in diesem flug zurück in
der luft stehen das erste mal überhaupt
kein problem zu sein das flugzeug ist
ziemlich groß also sehr träge um leichte
unruhen lassen sich mit etwas
fingerspitzengefühl ziemlich einfach
ausgleichen
jetzt will ich aber der landebahn kamen
desto mehr habe ich gemerkt wie wenig
plan nicht wirklich haben im prinzip
habe ich einfach versucht meine höhe und
mein tempo zu verringern ohne dabei zu
steil nach unten zu fliegen damit ich
nicht durchstarten ist im prinzip war
wie sie einfach versucht meine höhe und
mein tempo zu verringern ohne dabei zu
steil nach unten zu fliegen damit es
nicht durchstarten muss falls irgendwas
nicht stimmt viel spaß jetzt mit meiner
uncut landung ohne autopiloten und
autoren in einer airbus a320
[Musik]
denn auch so sauber hat ich habe jetzt
nicht gesehen
ich bin im endeffekt einfach nach gefühl
naja ich muss mal was sonst an und
wollen deshalb so geist kann viel spaß
gemacht und ich war so überwältigt davon
dass es im endeffekt wirklich geklappt
hat dieses flugzeug zu landen natürlich
ist es in keiner weise mit so einer
echten situation vergleichbar mann
handelt anders man denkt an das man ist
weniger gestresst dieser ganze kram aber
um ein bisschen einblick da rein zu
bekommen die sich so ein flugzeug fliegt
wie sich das handeln lässt wofür welche
knapp für sind war das glaube ich schon
senden und um sagen zu können dass man
schon mal ein flugzeug gelandet ist
deshalb ist auch das jedem von euch
empfehlen der sich für flugzeuge
interessiert lass mir leid da wenn ich
das video gefallen hat abonniert damit
ihr das video nicht verpasst was am
sonntag kommt zu diesen klamotten das
wird komplett wild shipping world
interessen in der video beschreibung
verlinkt wie lange muss ich hier noch
reden bis 17 minuten kommen wollen
diesmal waren wir wirklich eine große
freude kommentiert irgendwas was sich
durch leben wäre das wirklich perfekt
hoffentlich sind mittlerweile auf zehn
minuten macht's gut
ja danke fürs cannabis video und so das
war es